vous avez peut-être appris la nouvelle
ce soir lors que sarkozy a tenu à
assurer sa prestation pour vous parce
que c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas le coeur
très bien ce soir on a perdu
effectivement un frère on va dire un ami
un ancien collègue musicien chanteur
il s'agit de girard alger qui nous a
laissés malheureusement je dis donc
c'est dans la tristesse et dans
l'émotion que nous sommes venus ce soir
pour assurer notre prestation des
convois merci d'avoir répondu présent
une minute de silence à la mémoire de
notre camarade qui nous a laissé
je vous remercie
[Musique]
io muet
soit
je vois
mon goût
il
[Musique]
m
c est
[Musique]
m
à toute sa famille toutes nos
condoléances nos sincères condoléances
et puis on va aussi le remercier pour
tout le travail qu'il a fait pendant une
vingtaine d'années